τκλιχρειάζετα ακόμη περισσότερη ενισχς για το κομμάτι τις πληροπροστασί για ς α κτοκομμτι της πληροπροστασίας
είαι έναν κομμάτι δυναμικό δηλαδή όσον αυξάνονται ωσονικληματικές τη θείκες να το βούμε διαφοριδικά συνεχίζουμε
το τιθμό που συνεχίζουν πρέπει να υξάνονται και ιδικές μας ενέργειες είναι κάτι το οποίον
δυναμικών και δεν μπορεί να σταματήσει συνεοχώςι υπάρχει κάτι άλλο και κάτι επιπλέων που πρέπει
να κάνεις για να όχι για ναοχειρώσεις έτσι για να μπορείσς να προστατεύσεις των τόποσου
κείνον το οποίο μας εν διαφερεία μας και εναι εδώ που που εστιάζουμε δεν είναι
στο κομμάτι της καταστολής της κατάσβεσης τούτον μετά πουν να συμβείτο κακόπο και ι αμε
πρέπει να κάνει τον πρόγραμματισμόσου το πρώτο βήμα και καιαμε που πρέπει να εστιάζεις και
εκεί που πρέπει να δουλεύεις είναι να μην προκληθεί το πρόβλημα έτσι τωνα προλάβεις της
ζημια ως την προλαβαίνεις της ζημια την προλαβαίνεις με τον ααφερίς καυσημηνήλι με το προωθεί
στην καλιέργεια τς γής καιατί ναα πο τα βασικά πρόβλήματα που έχουμε με το αδνεις
δυνατότητας τις κοινότητες να μπορούν να κάμουν και ο γίνει της δικος τους σχεδιασμος άρα
τού των ενευθεωριτικώ ξεκινήσαμε ται είπαμενόότι ενισχίουμε των πρωτογενήντομέα μέσα από τις στρατηγική μας δίννουμε
εγκίνητρα και δυνατότητα να επιστρέψει κάποιος να καλιεργήσει το χαραφυναντύος νέος γιοργος ή και ήδι
φιστάμενοι να μεγαλώσουν και να δυναμώσουν μέσα πόυ ες καλλιέργειες οδώσαμε την δυνατότητα στις τοπικές
αρχές να μπορούν να μπαίνουν να καθαρίζουν τα τεμάχεια τα οποία ένακαταλελιμένα για να μας
βοηθήσουν να μεν έχουμε νεκεί μια μαζεμένι νήλι που μπορεί να είνα εφλεκι ενισχύσαμε το
τημα τα σομμε εκπαίδευση για το κομμάτι τις ελογχόμενης καύσεις έγινε πρι να πολίγεσμένες ιδικί
από την ισπανία δημιουργούμε πρωτόκολλα κα